en este vídeo vamos a explorar cómo a
medida que llevamos a cabo más
experimentos o pruebas la probabilidad
de experimentar debería acercarse cada
vez más a la probabilidad teórica a esto
se le conoce como ley de los grandes
números si solo realizamos unos cuantos
experimentos es posible que nuestra
probabilidad experimental sea diferente
a nuestra probabilidad teórica incluso
muy diferente pero a medida que llevamos
a cabo muchos más experimentos miles
millones miles de millones de
experimentos la posibilidad de que las
probabilidades experimentales y teóricas
sean muy diferentes
disminuirá radicalmente vamos a
visualizarlo de manera intuitiva esta es
una simulación creada por la editorial
macmillan de eeuu aquí tenemos una nota
con el url de la simulación esto nos va
a permitir simular muchos lanzamientos
de moneda para determinar la proporción
de caras que caigan aquí podemos decidir
si queremos que nuestra moneda esté
cargada o no en este momento dice que
tenemos un 50 por ciento de probabilidad
de que caiga cara si cambiamos esto
podemos hacer que el volado esté cargado
pero nosotros vamos a
con la probabilidad del 50 por ciento si
queremos ver la probabilidad real en
esta gráfica podemos marcar esta casilla
esto nos indica cuántos lanzamientos de
moneda vamos a echar cada vez comencemos
con 10 lanzamientos de moneda entonces
lo que el simulador va a hacer será
echar 10 lanzamientos de moneda en los
que la moneda tiene un 50% de
probabilidad de caer en cara y a medida
que vaya lanzando la moneda vamos a ver
la proporción total de caras que caigan
analicemos esto mientras empezamos a
lanzar la moneda que ocurre después de
10 lanzamientos de moneda como pueden
ver de hecho en el primer volado salió
cara entonces si queremos saber cuál es
nuestra probabilidad experimental
después de ese primer volado podemos
decir bueno con un solo experimento
obtuve cara así que parece que tenemos
el 100 por ciento de probabilidad de que
caiga cara pero en el segundo volado
obtuvimos cruz por lo que ahora la
proporción de que caiga cara después de
dos lanzamientos de moneda es del 50%
pero en el tercer volado volvió a caer
cruz por lo que ahora sólo uno de tres
lanzamientos de moneda o sea el 33 por
ciento dio como resultado cara en el
cuarto volado tenemos cruzo
lo que nos da un percentil 25 parece que
en el quinto volado el resultado fue
cara así que ahora tenemos tres cruces
de cinco lanzamientos de moneda o sea el
60 por ciento entonces aquí la
conclusión en general sería que cuando
tenemos seis experimentos es
completamente aceptable que la
probabilidad experimental sea distinta
de la probabilidad real y esto continúa
hasta llegar al noveno o décimo volado
pero qué sucede si lanzamos la moneda
muchas veces más vamos a echar otros 200
lanzamientos de moneda para ver qué pasa
entonces vamos a seguir echando
lanzamientos de moneda podemos ver que
estamos teniendo una racha con muchas
caras y ahora parece que son montones de
cruces luego unas cuantas cruces más
caras y luego otra racha de cruces
observen que incluso después de 215
lanzamientos de moneda nuestra
probabilidad de experimental todavía es
bastante diferente a nuestra
probabilidad teórica echemos otros 200
lanzamientos de moneda y veamos si
podemos hacer converger ambas
probabilidades a lo largo del tiempo lo
que estamos viendo aquí en tiempo real
es la ley de los grandes números a
medida que nuestra cantidad
cientos de monedas va siendo más grande
la probabilidad de que estas dos líneas
sean muy diferentes va disminuyendo por
supuesto que habrá momentos en que
obtendremos 10 o incluso 20 caras
consecutivas pero a lo largo del tiempo
se verán equilibradas por las veces en
que obtengamos una cantidad
desproporcionada de cruces
vamos a continuar echando lanzamientos
de moneda ya llevamos casi 800 y pueden
ver que las líneas se están convergiendo
estamos a punto de pasar los 1000
lanzamientos de moneda y pueden ver que
nuestra proporción ahora es del 48% nos
estamos acercando ya estamos en 1.165 y
la proporción es del 49 por ciento como
pueden ver cuando llevábamos
aproximadamente 200 lanzamientos de
moneda había una diferencia en la
proporción de lo que obtuvimos del
experimento y lo que esperábamos
teóricamente pero a medida que echamos
muchos más lanzamientos de moneda
estamos más cerca de que el 50 por
ciento de ellos hayan resultado en cara
y podemos seguir lanzando más y más
monedas y lo que vamos a ver es que a
medida que esta cantidad se incrementa
nos vamos a acercar cada vez más al 50%
debemos decir que sea imposible que
estas líneas vayan a separarse de nuevo
pero la probabilidad de que esto suceda
es cada vez menor entre más lanzamientos
de monedas echemos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo